from Benton Harbor in Michigan NBC
correspondent Shakil Brewster has this
update
well nearly every person in this country
east of the Rockies woke up this morning
to some brutal and frigid temperatures
others experiencing the conditions like
the ones you're seeing me in right now
in Benton Harbor they woke up to another
blizzard warning which means a lot of
this lake effect snow that continues to
come down this is something that folks
here have told me that they're used to
they know how to shovel they know how to
plow the snow but what becomes unusual
are these Gusty winds that they're
experiencing you see the wind whipping
around me pushing this powdery snow
that's both falling down and on the
ground up into the air what happens is
when you're on the roads that's when you
go from being able to see the car in
front of you to not being able to see
anything the visibility just completely
Fades away but if you look across the
country there are places where they have
it worse in Buffalo they're dealing with
the historic blizzard a travel ban was
put in effect yesterday other areas of
New York dealing with dramatic flooding
this storm is also take taking up power
as it makes its way through along to the
east coast and into the Northeast this
morning more than a half million people
woke up without power warming centers
have been opened and set up across the
country in anticipation of even more
power outages and of course there are
also the deaths associated with this
storm at least 17 people killed in uh
storm related injuries or in
storm-related situations that includes
four people in Ohio three people in
Kentucky the vast majority of those
deaths are connected to traffic
incidents and that's why you have
officials telling people to stay off the
road because this is unfortunately a
deadly misque mix with the constant snow
the heavy wind and these cold
temperatures which leads to that ice
IBC correspondents to kill Brewster
there